quatrième défaite en cinq matches la
mauvaise série se poursuit pour les
handballeuses de montigny le bretonneux
face à chambray 2e du classement et
toujours invaincu lésigny montée non
tenu bon pendant 20 minutes elle n'était
alors menés que d'un seul but on lisait
bien les les les shoots et les impacts
par rapport à la gardienne et et puis là
ça s'est déréglé ont peut-être par la
fatigue peut-être par le par le stress
aussi
mais c'est vrai qu'à chaque fois qu'on
était en échec aux shoots y avait une
contre attaque un but de l'autre côté
quoi six buts d'écart à la mi-temps le
début de la seconde période est plutôt
bien négocié par les joueuses de
montigny plus agressives en défense
elles multiplient quand même les fautes
techniques score final 25 37 et une
deuxième défaite à domicile cette saison
dernière du classement avec seulement 6
points lésigny montée ne reste soudé pas
de crise à l'ordre du jour on reste
motivés parce que l'année dernière on a
vécu un peu le même scénario ont perdu
tous nos matches au début et on a tous
remontés à la fin est comme la poule
elle est assez serré bas on garde espoir
les filles sont vraiment soudée il y
aurait une crise si on se
on se disputait sur le terrain ou dans
les vestiaires ce qui n'est pas le cas
j'ai un groupe extraordinaire
qui a besoin de travailler prochain
match pour la s montigny samedi prochain
avec un déplacement à saint maur un club
aussi mal classés avec une seule
victoire en championnat
[Applaudissements]